[Captions by Mary V. at Y Translator]
Super glue is really common stuff
and we wannna see what happens
if you mix this super glue with
a couple of different substances.
[Music]
Here's the basic idea.
We'll try mixing some super glue
with some baking soda.
We'll try mixing some
super glue with the water,
and then we'll try mixing it with
the water and baking soda combined.
First off, we're gonna start
with some small-scale tests
using just a little bit of
superglue and a little bit of water,
and we wanted to try water
because it's so unbelievably common
it's everywhere,
and I've never really seen
any sort of large quantity
of superglue mixing with water.
For our small-scale tests,
we'll just drip out
a little bit of water
and a little bit of our
glue onto this piece of foil.
As it stands, the water
and the superglue look
pretty much identical.
So I'm going to add just a couple
of drops of blue food coloring
to our water
so we can tell what's the water
and what's the superglue.
[Music]
The reason we're doing
this outside is because superglue
has some pretty powerful fumes,
and doing this inside,
I think I would become
overwhelmed by them
just by opening the lid of the bottle.
I got a really strong whiff of it.
I'm very glad that I'm outside
where there's a nice breeze.
Alright.
Just try just putting down a
few drops of our super glue here.
Little puddle.
Now, let's see what happens
if we drip a drop of water
into the middle of that super glue.
Some reaction definitely took place.
We have this sort of stringy,
gooey plastic that's formed.
It's, it's glued itself quite
well to the foil below it.
Let's just add more water just
over that whole spill of superglue.
To me, it looks like wherever
the water and the superglue
actually come in contact,
they cure in a thin sheet.
But of course as soon as there's
a thin sheet of cured super glue,
it can't touch any more of the water.
It kind of makes a bag
or a balloon around it.
Now we've seen what happens
if we drip water into super glue.
Let's see what happens
if we drip super glue into water.
We've got a little puddle of water
that has some food coloring in it.
See what happens if
we add a drip of super glue.
Interesting.
It kind of like looks like
it splashed outwards
but then there's like
a center drop in the middle.
With our little bamboo skewer here,
I can lift up underneath
that very thin sheet.
You can see that it's cured.
Sort of string where the glue
that's still in the water
keeps reacting with the water.
This is actually fairly
similar to how nylon is made.
Oh hey, it's made of super glue.
So it sticks to things like my gloves.
Okay, same as before we did a small test.
Let's try a little bit more.
Just cover that whole area
of water in superglue at once.
[Music]
I might have just discovered how
Spider Man makes his web fluid.
Well, there we go.
There's a beautiful view right there.
Just a blob of cured super glue,
and that happened by pouring
the super glue onto
a large blob of water.
I really want to take
this up one more level.
So, I've got my whole dropper
full of super glue here,
and I'm just gonna see
what happens if I squirt all of it
into this cup of
bluefied water at once.
[Music]
We've got something crazy going
on at the bottom of this cup.
Oooh it's squishy.
That is gonna be hard
like the other plastic
but this is very very gooey...
Ah! And sticky.
It's sticky!
Well I can get new gloves.
Here's our sticky gooey plastic.
This is what happens
when you just pour aww!
Ow, ow! It's hot!
Ugh!
Exothermic reaction when
superglue catalyzes against warm.
Whoo! That started burning
my fingers a little bit.
Yeah. That's that's really very warm.
Very toasty gonna grab some more gloves.
The next thing we're going
to try is some of our baking soda.
And we're gonna be using baking soda
because in a lot of hobby circles,
it's well-known that baking soda
causes superglue to catalyze
almost immediately.
It's a popular way to fill
some gaps or do small repairs
on model building and things like that.
You take baking soda, fill in the gap,
add some super glue on top of it,
and it'll catalyze and
harden almost immediately.
You can then sand it down
and paint over it.
It's a pretty cool trick.
Like with the water, we'll start
with a small pile of the baking soda,
and we'll drip some super glue
onto it and watch what happens.
[Music]
That is solid. That is solid. That is solid.
Let's see how quickly it turns solid.
I'm gonna poke it right
after it drips down on.
[Music]
Already solid.
Not even sticky anymore.
Let's see if we can make
a taller pile and drip it on there,
and see if we can lift
it off without sticking to the foil.
[Music]
Our super glue down onto
the baking soda.
Cured immediately.
Now we can just lift it right off.
[Music]
We just have this little piece of
hardened plastic like substance.
I know I don't have very good
leverage on it but it's really durable too.
There we go.
Finally got it to snap.
Sort of a translucent colored plastic.
We're bringing the scale up a little bit.
I have a slightly larger pile of baking soda,
and this time I'm just gonna squirt all this
dripper of super glue right down into it.
Here it goes.
[Music]
Those fumes coming off a bitt.
Remember how I said
it's an exothermic reaction,
that means it's getting hot.
There was enough of it that it made it all
the way down through the baking soda pile
and that is fused onto the foil.
Well we did the super glue
into baking soda.
Same as the water,
let's try reversing it.
Let's have a little puddle of the super glue,
and drop some baking soda down into it,
and watch what happens.
[Music]
Everywhere that had both
baking soda and super glue
has hardened into plastic.
And it does not want
to peel off the foil this time.
That is pretty good and glued on there.
It starts tearing as soon as I try.
Our superglue combined
with water cures pretty quickly.
Our super glue combined with baking soda
cures almost instantly.
I feel like I really need to see what happens
if I combine baking soda in
the water and then add the super glue.
Will the dissolved baking soda
make it react even faster?
Will make it slower?
Will it put off a lot of heat?
We saw some good exothermic reactions.
Will that keep happening even
if it's in the water?
Let's find out.
[Music]
Once again, I am going to
add just a little bit of blue.
Cause I think that will make it
easier to see what goes on.
All right let's start with
one drip of super glue
into our heavily saturated
baking soda water.
That cured quick,
and then like crystallized afterward.
[Music]
Kinda look like little jellyfish.
Oooh bigger jellyfish oooh wow.
And that started putting off smoke
or fumes or something without
a whole lot going on.
This isn't as blue as when we
mix it with just the water.
So something about the baking soda
is making it so it doesn't mix as much.
[Music]
So the baking soda water really
makes the super glue react quickly,
and I even tried scaling it up a little
bit by dripping in more drops at once.
But what I wanna do is take the
rest of this bottle of super glue,
which you can see is still mostly full
and this whole cup of slightly
blue baking soda saturated water,
and pour both of them into
this jar at the same time.
I wanna see what kind
of reaction we get
when that much super glue reacts
with that much baking soda water.
Okay here we go.
Baking soda water.
Huge amounts of super glue going
in at the same time.
Three two one.
[Music]
Oh I don't know what we just made there.
Jar's a little bit warm.
Nothing crazy.
Well getting hotter.
The top of it's quite hot actually.
The bottom, less down here.
More up here.
There we go.
That's about 6 ounces of superglue,
and probably 10 ounces of water
and that, that was crazy.
It looks like I took several plastic bags,
and shoved them down
into a jar full of water.
I am kind of curious about
the inside of this.
So I think I want to try
breaking the jar open
and seeing if I can get any of
that plastic out.
It might just be glued to the walls.
All right let's find out
what is inside this jar here.
[Music]
So that's water.
Not sticky.
[Music]
That  clearly was super glue.
Very sticky.
[Music]
Here's our blob.
Our blob of super glue,
baking soda and water.
This stuff has kind of an
interesting texture.
It's not too heavy,
and parts of it are quite soft and squishy.
I can just drive my fingers right into them.
It's like it's sheets and
compressed plastic.
which I guess is just how it cast.
It's not actually compressed,
it started it this way.
[Music]
Now, I did this experiment because
I had never seen a large quantity
of superglue get mixed
with water or baking soda,
or especially baking
soda saturated water.
So this is really just a discovery.
I wanted to know what's gonna happen.
So I tried it out.
And fortunately,
I didn't have to go out and buy
300 tiny little bottles of super glue.
You can buy the large bottles online.
That's really nice.
It's fun to learn what will happen.
This is just some
extremely basic chemistry
watching what happens when you pour
super glue in the baking soda water.
And now I know.
Now, I know what will happen.
Turns into compressed
plastic bag jellyfishes.
Or something.
Guys, we've got more for you to see.
The little box up at the top will
transport you directly to our last video,
and you should go check it out.
The box at the bottom shows
you what YouTube thinks
you need to be watching now,
and if you hit this bomb,
you'll be subscribed to our channel
so you never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.